STAY WHEN IT IS FRIDAY, AND
THAT MEANS IT IS TIME FOR --
♪ ♪
>> Laura: OF COURSE, COLIN
KAEPERNICK WITH THE SUPER BOWL,
SOME VIDEO.
AND >> ALL RIGHT, RAYMOND, WHAT
IS GOING ON WITH COLIN
KAEPERNICK AND THE SUPER BOWL?
I HAVE NEVER HEARD OF COLIN
KAEPERNICK BUT HE'S BEEN AROUND.
, A LOT OF MAJOR BUZZ HANGING
OVER IT.
AND COLIN KAEPERNICK, A NUMBER
OF CELEBRITIES WHOM I NOTE, THEY
HAVE DARED TO USE -- AND HIS
PROTEST.
IN MAROON 5, >>
SO.
THE BASICALLY CROSS A PICKET
LINE
I HAVE NEVER SEEN NONAFFILIATED
ATHLETE TALK ABOUT MORE SINCE
RUDY.
THIS GUY --
>> Laura: IT IS REALLY
RIDICULOUS.
THE PUBLIC HAS MOVED ON BUT
LATER IN THE SAME INTERVIEW,
DEREK ROSE WENT FURTHER BLAMING
HIS TROUBLES ON, YOU WATCH.
>> THE COLLUSION ACTUALLY WAS
THE NFL KOWTOW TO THE PRESIDENT.
THE SO-CALLED DIVISIVENESS, THE
CAUSE, WAS ACTUALLY GENERATED UP
BY A RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
EFFORT.
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND.
>> MUELLER HAS TO INVESTIGATE
THE NFL.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Laura: NO, NO, NO.
THIS IS THE NUTTY STUFF THAT
ONLY HERE IT GOES FROM SEAN
LEAVY FAME CAN COME UP WITH,
OKAY?
HE GOES BACK TO SHAWN LEAVY,
THIS IS AGAIN SPOILING, I KNOW
YOU'RE UPSET ABOUT THE SAINTS
AND WERE NOT TALKING ABOUT THE
SAINTS ANYMORE.
>> Larry: I AM.
ACTUALLY I'M RESERVING THE RIGHT
TO TALK ABOUT THE SAINTS.
>> Laura: WE HAVE MOVED ON.
>> LOOK, LAURA --
'S BE WHEN LOT OF GRIEF.
>> Larry: THERE ARE A LOT OF
REASONS TO GET UPSET WITH THE
SUPER BOWL.
I CAN THINK OF TWO OF THEM
MISSED CALLS AND NEW NET NATION,
BOYCOTT MOVE THIS WEEKEND.
AND I CAN TELL YOU ABOUT.
BUT THE IDEA THAT WE SHOULD GETS
UPSET ABOUT ENTERTAINMENT AND
COLIN KAEPERNICK, THIS IS
RIDICULOUS AND THE NFL SHOULD
MOVE PAST THIS.
>> Laura: A VIDEO OF A WOMAN
IN AN AIRPLANE WHO BEGAN FAT
SHAMING HER FELLOW PASSENGERS ON
A UNITED FLIGHT FROM VEGAS TO
NEW WORK NEW JERSEY, HERE IS THE
VIDEO.
>> I DON'T KNOW HOW I'M GOING TO
DO THIS THE NEXT FOUR HOURS.
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE.
THEY ARE SQUISHING ME.
>> WILL YOU FIND HER ANOTHER
SEAT BECAUSE I WILL NOT BE
ABUSED BY [BLEEP] [BLEEP] WOMAN.
I CANNOT TOLERATE IT.
>> I CANNOT SAY HERE BECAUSE
IT'S SO BIG.
>> YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
YOURSELF.
YOU SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF
>> Laura: WAIT A SECOND,
RAYMOND, DID SHE SAY I.E. EAT
SALAD?
IS THAT WHAT SHE SAID THEY ARE?
OH, MY GOD.
>> Larry: NO ONE SHOULD BE
VERBALLY ABUSE FOR THE WAY SHE
LOOKS AND THIS WOMAN WAS WRONG
BUT I'M GLAD THEY WALKED HER OFF
BUT I'M GLAD THEY WALKED HER OFO
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, I
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, S
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, M
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, A
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, H
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, Z
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, E
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, W
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, T
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, H
THE FLIGHT BUT WITH THAT SAID, R
FLIGHT SOME DAYS, LAURA WHEN I
FIND MYSELF IN THE MIDDLE SEAT.
I WAS JUST ON A PLANE AND A
RATHER LARGE FELLOW PLOPPED DOWN
NEXT TO ME AND HE LIFTED UP THAT
ARMREST.
NOW, THAT IS LIKE AN OPENING
WAR.
I'M FIGHTING.
THAT IS A BORDER NO ONE SHOULD
CROSS.
THAT ARM -- THAT ARMREST SHOULD
STAY DOWN.
I SYMPATHIZE.
THE SEATS ARE GOING SMALLER AND
PEOPLE GOING THE OTHER DIRECTION
AND YOU UNDERSTAND WHERE THIS
WOMAN IS COMING FROM BUT THIS IS
THE WRONG WAY TO DO IT.
HERE SHE IS ON THE WAY OUT,
WATCH THIS.
>> >> Laura: WAIT, WAIT, WHAT?
>> Raymond: SHE IS SCREWED TO
THE VERY END.
>> Laura: DOES SHE KNOW THAT
PEOPLE ARE FILMING HER?
PEOPLE ARE ALWAYS FILMING YOU,
FLYING IS NOT EASY TODAY, BUT
THERE'S GOT TO BE ANOTHER WAY TO
WORK THIS OUT.
BORDERS AND SEEDS, YOU DO PAY
FOR YOUR SEAT SO YOU WANT YOUR
BORDERS AND FOREST, BUT NOT THAT
WAY.
>> Laura: THE AIRLINE SHOULD
NOT BE SHRINKING THE SEATS.
>> A RECURRING SEGMENT, THE DAYS
AND NIGHTS OF ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ.
AOC.
THE 29-YEAR-OLD QUEENS
CONGRESSWOMAN POSTED SKIN CARE
REGIMEN AND DID YOU KNOW, LAURA,
DID YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD ALWAYS
WASH YOUR FACE TWICE WHEN YOU
WEAR MAKEUP?
SHE SAYS, ONCE WITH OIL AND THEN
WITH SOAP OR YOU CAN JUST PUT A
MAKEUP WIPE AND IT SHOULD STAY
THERE.
AND THEN SHE OFFERED SOME ADVICE
ABOUT WHAT YOU SHOULD WEAR AT
HOME.
>> MATCHING PAJAMA SETS IS KEY.
TO PRODUCTIVITY.
PEOPLE TALK ABOUT HAVING A WORK
UNIFORM, BUT WHAT DOES NOT GET
TALKED ABOUT IS HAVING KIND OF A
LOUNGE UNIFORM OF SORTS SO THAT
YOU HAVE SOMETHING THAT YOU WEAR
WHEN YOU ARE WORKING, AND YOU
HAVE A SET THING THAT YOU WEAR
WHEN YOU ARE NOT WORKING.
NOW, THAT WHOLE CONCEPT MAY SEEM
STRANGE, BUT, TRULY HAVING
WORK-LIFE BALANCE IS CRITICAL TO
MENTAL HEALTH.
>> Laura: NOW, I'M JUST
THINKING, I'M JUST THINKING,
DOES NANCY PELOSI HAVE THAT
ATHLETE SURE, FORMAL, CASUAL
JAMMIES, WE CALL THEM JAMMIES AT
MY HOUSE.
DOES SHE HAVE THAT KIND OF --